so uh it's great to reconnect
i got to meet you and your beautiful
family in the magical town of yellow
spring ohio
this summer as part of freaking camp
chapelle
it was amazing i've got a t-shirt
uh i've got memories i've got
there really is like a summer camp i
ended up i ended up going pretty crazy
there i bought them i bought a
scooter and then three other motorcycles
and so somebody had an accident on my
moped like
they on my motorcycle and they hurt
themselves pretty badly like they
cracked their shoulder and stuff oh wait
wait so that that happened before
i got on michelle's moped and was like
running around yeah so everybody was
looking at you on there like
not andrew oh that's why everyone was
scared shitless because i was like guys
i'm an adult male like this isn't like
uh
you know freaking harley or something
like it's that's what you might think
that's what you would think next thing
you know parking
parking a scooter can fracture to your
shoulders i still to this day don't know
how he did it but you know
i'm glad he's okay matthew i'm sorry i
love you i hope you're well
yeah shout out to you matthew hope your
shoulders are all right i'm so glad that
at least some people were documenting
parts of
uh the camp experience because i you
know i know that that someone was
working on a
project for it and i can see exactly how
you got addicted to buying two wheeled
vehicles there because
it's summer it's beautiful you're just
roaming around
uh and so i see why you didn't stop at
the moped i defend you mo
i defend you and your three motorcycles
uh on top of it
i appreciate i needed that you know i i
was going really smart because i was
like yeah i haven't ridden motorcycles
at least 12 years
so let's get like a 120cc little scoot
situation
put a boombox that's almost bigger than
the entire
scooter itself on the back of it enjoy
these you know
cinematic beautiful gorgeous
you go there like you know you just look
out it's like
americana cornfields like
sunshine it was gorgeous i would pretend
like i'm on american pickers i would
constantly like
stop and she's like oh what is this item
this antique from the 40s it was very
nice like stop at a rusted filled
farm or something like and i would
attempt to buy
some of their junk that's in the yard
that's like one of my favorite pastimes
when i was just trying to decompress it
was so much fun it was so much fun
so how did your wife feel about the
purchases
this is a common question more common
more common than i ever thought it would
be
yeah it just like i don't i didn't
really tell her
[Laughter]
i just did it i was very smart about it
though i was like a traditional arab
trader i was like i don't know you know
i was really like checking out the
market what are the pricing honey i
bought the death machine smart i was a
savvy death machine buyer
and then she divorced me you know that's
how that's how this all works out
you know it's a very clear progression
uh you know that that's why they have
that uh divorce lawyer office attached
to the motorcycle dealing now
[Laughter]
i bet there's a few of them dude this is
a billion dollar business idea that's
why
uh i'm the entrepreneur i've got a
vision
uh you could attach all sorts of
mid-life crises
services to the motorcycle dealership
it's like what you're here buying a bike
would you like
these brand new overpriced sunglasses
that make you look
30 years younger that's how i justify my
purchases
and like sunglasses i have a you know
you can't just buy regular sunglasses or
else you just destroy them throw them
out you won't respect them
you have to buy something of value that
you have to care for them
especially if they have like resale
value as well like oh no i can't lose
these
where are these it makes you way more
conscious of them well
i i think to me there's like a threshold
where something becomes real
and uh it's reality often is
commensurate to whatever you paid for it
you know it's like if you buy like five
dollar sunglasses they're not real you
can like lose them sit on them
without no one cares but that as soon as
you break through a certain investment
threshold
then all of a sudden it's like okay this
is an actual item of mine that i
associate with myself
and it says something about me and i
take pride in or whatever it is
what is that threshold for me when does
something become real
when does it become real like if it
doesn't exist
otherwise it's like bad this is garbage
so uh so i'm in atlanta georgia i don't
know if you like i'm
campaigning for the special senate
candidate bits
and i was uh getting some food for my
families on those curbside pick up
things and so i stopped to park the car
there's an automated reader uh and i was
like i don't know how long it's gonna
take me to pick up this food
so i stick the credit card in the reader
and i'm just jamming in like ad time ad
time ad time because like i was like i
don't i don't want to
calculate like like the like the
25 cent per 8 minute threshold i don't
want to like cut it that close because
like
who knows how long that like some of
these these places take
so like that that parking experience was
like below my reality threshold i was
just like
like let's just make it so that i'm i'm
not gonna have to deal with this for a
minute it's one reason i i became so
passionate about universal basic income
i mean there are a lot of reasons but
uh just like we're now such a society of
folks who are making that
time money trade-off all of the time uh
and
i still do it obviously um though now
the threshold has to be higher for me to
say like okay
it's going to be worth my cycles to try
and save that quarter whatever it is
when i was a kid growing up the child of
immigrants in this country like a
quarter
was precious and i would go to the
arcade and then play it and then just
try and win for as long as possible it's
like that you had to like stretch
the value of that quarter to a point
where uh you know like you could
entertain yourself all day
ideally that street fighter game at the
corner store
before high school or after high school
was like the one
you know that's that's the game if you
can just make that quarter keep
that that was it that that was like our
test of value as like
a teenager it's like if you can win and
then it became
not only can you win but can you win
with an obscure character
it's like it's not enough to be good at
you or guile
and defend your quarter but then
eventually when you're like i'm just
gonna screw around
i'm just gonna choose blanca never
choose [ __ ]
oh my god never knew how to play with
that guy
and then there would be like this ooh
from like the people being like he's
choosing blanca it's like it's like a
real expression of
of like confidence or cockiness the
ultimate cockiness was de halsim which
is now that i reflect on it a somewhat
racist portrayal of like a hindu warrior
whose limb stretch
i love how you just just like sat there
for a second now that i think about it
just like
maybe it was a racist portrayal of just
seeing this
kid like i saw the kid in you like now
that i think about it maybe
maybe i shouldn't have played with that
character well he was also awful as a
character
you know like he was like the sure the
closest thing to a sure loss
was if you played with that guy it could
be that mo and i are somewhat dating
ourselves
it seems like you and i came of age
around the same time but i feel like if
the kids know street fighter i hope it's
eternal i hope it's one of those things
i saw my nephews playing a street
fighter in mortal kombat
just over thanksgiving nice yes
but it was like wow oh this is the
mortal kombat y'all are growing up with
that's pretty cool
is it much better than ours it's so much
better the graphics are insane arguable
no it's
it depends i actually like the classic i
mean
just seeing what they're dealing with i
mean seeing the graphics i kind of miss
the
the dodgy graphics and the you know and
and seeing the pit of death you know
like it's a little bit different a
little bit more group
like really gruesome actually i am
definitely old enough now where i look
back on certain things as like the
standard of the golden years you know
what i mean like that like
um 90s video games uh
80s and 90s music like it comes on i'm
like oh it doesn't matter they don't
make this like they used to
you reminded me of a joke uh an amazing
comedian
uh jack mayberry he's like you have a
right around uh
uh with somebody old they'll always tell
you where things didn't used to be
you know you just be sitting there going
see that there it wasn't there
all the way from there all the way to
wall over there that wasn't there either
hey look at that that wasn't there that
wasn't there from all the way from there
to all the way to whoa
there it wasn't there hell it was it was
just dark there's nothing out here you
know
so that's what you reminded me of right
now that's actually a reasonable
summation of what's gone wrong with the
country
which is that like it really is uh hey
we need to change things versus
no let's stay the same uh like
have the same rules for ever uh and then
we don't really have the capacity to
actually change some of these
institutions
explain that a lot of people are upset
over the fact that
the electoral college and the popular
vote aren't lining up
terribly well so you have folks who
want to get rid of the electoral college
but in order to get rid of the electoral
college you need a super majority of
states to get on board with that and
like there's zero chance that kansas and
nebraska are going to be like you're
right
like we shouldn't have this much say so
it's one of those things we look and be
like look this is not changing in the
way that
some people are arguing in any realistic
fashion as long as you have
um that standard there are a lot of
things that right now we're having a
trouble we're having trouble
shifting because there's really no
consensus or no
governing majority uh and it's something
that
makes me very sad it's why i'm in
georgia honestly is that
i hoped that we would have a government
that could actually address some of the
big problems
coming into 2021 because we've got major
problems
uh and instead it looks like we're going
to
struggle with a degree of gridlock and
dysfunction
for the foreseeable and and so you have
this framework that's set up
that that says what you can do and you
can't change it unless you had let's
let's call it a super majority let's
call it
60 senators or whatever it is in the
current rules uh
and and so the frustration is setting in
on both sides
we're having increasingly incoherent
conversations about it
and it makes me very sad it makes me
very sad too like i i told you in the
beginning of
this conversation i mean you were the
first campaign that i ever
vote i mean like not only did i want to
vote for you but i contributed to
oh thank you yes thank you for listening
in i hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]